[Musica]
volevo cominciare
facendo un piccolo esperimento siccome
quando siamo in un auditorium
siamo tutti quanti seduti guardando
verso la stessa direzione
questo è un po simile a quello che
succede stando in un aereo ad esempio e
possiamo immaginare chiudendo gli occhi
per qualche secondo invece di trovarci
su una navicella spaziale che viaggia
nello spazio interstellare nell'oscurità
tra le stelle concentriamoci un attimo e
pensiamo che sia così
se poi li abbiamo gli occhi torniamo
alla realtà forse a quelli di voi che ci
hanno creduto per questi pochi secondi
potranno ancora sentire l'ebrezza di
questo viaggio interstellare
e questa non è una sensazione fallace
perché sulla terra noi siamo davvero un
viaggio interstellare
la terra è una navicella spaziale che si
muove attorno al sole una velocità più o
meno di 1.200 chilometri all'ora
non è poco e insieme al sole si muove
attorno al centro della galassia a circa
800 mila chilometri orari
quindi queste brezza della velocità si
può sentire davvero immaginandola la
terra è un'astronave che con la sua
atmosfera ci protegge da dalle eccessive
radiazioni solari o dalle eccessive
radiazioni che ci provengono dal resto
dell'universo da sorgenti forse ancora
sconosciuta
ebbene su questa strona ve l'astronave è
stata fotografata in questa foto che un
famoso astronomo kalsa cannes nel 1990
ha definito la foto del bluetooth sia un
pallido puntino azzurro una foto
scattate da una sonda che si chiama
voyager 1 in viaggio tuttora ai confini
del sistema solare e questa sonda appena
oltrepassato saturno fu fatta girare
guardare verso la terra
per una foto tra gli anelli di saturno
in cui si intravede un puntino
insignificante all'apparenza eppure
kalsa ghana ci ha fatto notare che
questo puntino contiene tutto ciò che
noi conosciamo tutte le nostre storie
tutte le persone che abbiamo conosciuto
tutti i nostri sogni
sembra insignificante eppure è molto
significativo per noi contiene conterrà
anche il nostro futuro
contiene attualmente le nostre scelte
scelte che siamo portati a compiere
quotidianamente
bella la mia scelta molti anni fa fu
quella di dedicarmi proprio allo spazio
che circonda la navicella spaziale su
cui ritroviamo sia il pianeta terra
una scelta che molte volte pensato forse
in una visione quasi nichilista potrebbe
sembrare inutile una scelta di uno
studio di un qualcosa di non non utile
eppure io ho avuto la libertà di poter
fare questa scelta grazie anche al luogo
in cui sono nato grazie alla mia
famiglia non è retorica è vero è una
grande fortuna però questa libertà è un
po io l'ho visualizzata sempre come
trovarsi al centro di una piazza e poter
scegliere qualsiasi delle strade che da
questa piazza si diramano poi però se la
strada non si percorre la libertà
scompare e rimane solamente una potenza
non un atto bene nella mia scelta di
quasi inconsapevole di dedicarmi allo
studio dell'universo
io ho guidato da all'inizio da un regalo
piccolo telescopio che mi regalarono
quando avevo 10 anni che poi ha fornito
quel quel giusto elemento per poter poi
interpretare correttamente quelle che
sarebbero dovuto essere le mie scelte in
futuro ma nell'ambito della ricerca
quotidianamente dobbiamo fare delle
scelte
per ciò che riguarda gli argomenti da
investigare e quando si parla
dell'universo questi argomenti sono
pressoché infiniti quindi come si
sceglie un argomento di ricerca secondo
me deve avere tre elementi primo deve
incuriosirci alla follia deve essere una
grande che suscita da una grande
passione noi ma dobbiamo assicurarci che
sia un elemento affrontabile con gli
strumenti che la ricerca scientifica
attuale possiede e in terzo deve essere
un qualcosa che possa interessare
marginalmente la comunità scientifica e
non solo bene io ho deciso quindi come è
stato detto in precedenza di studiare i
campi magnetici astrofisici calamite
tutti i corpi spaziali celesti sono
delle vere e proprie calamite come
quelle che abbiamo sul nostro
frigorifero il cui campo magnetico però
si modifica si evolve non sappiamo da
dove in alta quindi un grande mistero
dell'universo e al contempo invece mi
sono fatto affascinare da lo spazio più
vicino al sistema solare quindi senza
andarmi a perdere nell'universo profondo
spazio in cui si possono trovare altri
pianeti cosiddetti pianeti extrasolari o
esopianeti in italiano
questo è uno studio che inizia a qualche
anno fa anche allora guidato più che
altro dal voler collaborare con un amico
soprattutto per le sue caratteristiche e
capacità umane oltre che quelle tecniche
e scientifiche e decidemmo proprio di
cominciare osservare proxima centauri
che progetto forse più ovvio da
osservare essendo quello più vicino al
sole di natura
l'oggetto stellare di natura stellare
più vicino al sole proxima centauri come
potete immaginare è oggetto di molte
ricerche
ebbene noi studiando proxima che può
essere immaginato come una stella è una
stella rossa ma nana rossa e non
sappiamo cosa cosa c'è intorno a proxima
centauri in questa illustrazione ci sono
due pianeti
e queste due stelle sono invece
rappresentano gli altri gli altri due
membri del sistema triplo a cui proxima
appartiene sia alpha centauri a e b
ebbene noi ci siamo messi a studiare la
luce proveniente da proxima e abbiamo
trovato delle oscillazioni
dell'oscillazione che in queste in
questa figura rappresentiamo una
l'abbiamo abbiamo ricostruito ciò che
era già stato scoperto sia l'esistenza
di un pianeta chiamato proxima b pianeta
piccolo che orbita in 11 giorni attorno
a questa stella e poi ne abbiamo detto
ci sembra che ci sia qualcos'altro e
quindi abbiamo questa foto
questa questa questo grafico che
illustra le illustrazioni di uno che è
tutto rock pianeta candidato prossima c
questi numeri cosa sono
sono le cosiddette velocità radiali
ossia le fluttuazioni che la stella
proxima centauri compie nella direzione
della nostra linea di vista guardate il
prossimo i centauri si trova a 42 anni
di distanza 4 a 2 anni luce di distanza
sia una distanza non umana la luce
impiega più di quattro anni per arrivare
qui per paragone la luce dal sole
impiega otto minuti mentre quella della
luna un secondo invece queste velocità
sono velocità umane perché sono velocità
dell'ordine di 1 o 2 metri al secondo
ossia una camminata lenta o veloce
quindi se ci penso descrivendolo mi
sembra quasi incredibile che tuttora
possiamo misurare la velocità di una
stella lontana dell'ordine di un metro
al secondo
eppure sono strumenti di cui la scienza
moderna è fornita è frutto del lavoro di
anni di persone scienziati comuni che si
sono messi in comunità che hanno
lavorato insieme
ovviamente questo pianeta candidato io
non lo definisco come una scoperta non
mi piace avete definito con una scoperta
ma come un risultato forse come una
porta che apre una sala piena di altre
domande
questo grafico invece mostra la
popolazione di tutti gli esopianeti
conosciuti finora un grafico fatto dal
dal gruppo di ricerca del satellite
kepler che ha osservato centinaia di
migliaia di stelle ricerca di pianeti
extrasolari tuttora non è più in
funzione e un grafico che mostra tutti i
pianeti scoperti con vari metodi non
solo le velocità radiali ma anche
transito imagin diretto sono metodi
molto tecnici e li mette mette il loro
periodo orbitale in termini di giorni
come funzione della loro dimensione in
termini di relazione alla terra
ebbene in questo grafico in cui si
possono vedere diverse popolazioni da
pianeti di tipo giuliano caldo mondi di
lava pianeti rocciosi bene proxima ci si
colloca qui su questo triangolo che loro
definiscono frontiera e quindi un
risultato alla di frontiera potrebbe
aprire la scoperta di nuovi altri
pianeti si trovino qui che abbiano
queste caratteristiche lunghi periodi
orbitali e piccola massa e proprio per
questo è un risultato in discussione
discusso che andrà discusso negli anni e
andrà approvato con altre con altre
osservazioni benissimo ma tutto ciò è
forse affascinante almeno per me lo è ma
qual è l'utilità di tutto ciò potrebbe
chiedersi qualcuno noi sappiamo che
l'astronomia così come la scienza in
generale genere fa da apripista scopre
qualcosa di nuovo lo sviluppa e poi ci
regala nuove tecnologie
che magari oggi abbiamo nelle nostre
tasche questo è un qualcosa di risaputo
però io credo che non sia l'unico
impatto che l'astronomia in particolare
l'astrofisica possa dare alla comunità e
mi sono sempre un po scervellato anche
insieme ad altri colleghi perché
parlando quotidianamente i corpi celesti
lontani si perde un po a volte il
contatto con la realtà si può perdere
quindi come tornare con i piedi per
terra
questa è una domanda che ci siamo spesso
fatti io e amici colleghi e 11 anni fa
ci rendono idea perché non utilizzare
l'astronomia come campo di discussione
come merce di scambio culturale con
altre popolazioni come grimaldello per
aprire quei forzieri che tutti i ragazzi
credo che vanno a scuola e anche quelli
che non ci vanno hanno nelle loro teste
nei loro cuori e che sono piene di
curiosità pieni di stimoli ma a volte
non riescono a essere aperti io credo
che l'astronomia possa essere per la sua
natura stessa un grimaldello un qualcosa
che possa stimolare davvero il pensiero
critico dei ragazzi
bene così nacque questo progetto che si
chiama galileo mobile con l'idea di
dieci anni fa di andare di fare una sola
volta di girare una parte del sud
america visitare piccoli villaggi sulle
ande parlare di astronomia come noi la
conosciamo ai ragazzi delle scuole di
villaggio in cui l'astronomia genere non
arriva e sentire da loro le loro storie
sentire da loro qual è la loro
tradizione spesso centinaia millenario
sentire da loro le loro domande
le loro idee e farli sentire parte di
una comunità globale non esclusi non
esclusi quindi abbiamo cominciato
abbiamo visitato diversi paesi
con questo progetto con tali da mobile
dall'india all'uganda e poi ultimamente
negli ultimi due anni abbiamo deciso che
era forse il caso di compiere un altro
passo il passo che vuole utilizzare il
nuovo sembra un passo più grande della
gamba ma proviamoci
puoi utilizzare questo passo
l'astronomia come mezzo per la pace
questi sono nati due progetti uno si
chiama columba per gli l'uomo ball
columba che opera a cipro e mette
insieme ragazzi che vanno a scuola delle
due parti divisa e di cipro nella parte
cipriota turca nella parte cipriota
greco e ultimamente abbiamo usato invece
l'astronomia di nuovo per un altro
progetto che si chiama napoli che
significa pleiadi in una lingua una
lingua berbera le pleiadi sono un
ammasso di stelle masso aperto di stelle
nella costellazione del toro
ebbene a manara si è rivolto e si
rivolge tuttora e si rivolgerà a persona
e bimbi della popolazione saharawi una
popolazione di rifugiati che dovrebbe
vivere viveva nello stato che si trova a
sud del marocco sarà dell'ovest e poi
per cause che non sto qui a discutere è
dovuto spostarsi ha dovuto spostarsi in
più di 40 anni fa nel sud nel sud ovest
dell'algeria e da 40 anni vivono in
campi profughi che nel frattempo sono
diventati vere e proprie città bene
pensando a questo progetto
ovviamente i dubbi erano enormi ma loro
lavorano ben altri problemi non quello
di discutere ed astronomia ma noi non ci
siamo arresi anche contro i nostri
stessi dubbi abbiamo deciso di andar li
ha mandati lì non più di un mese fa un
mese fa ottobre e vi garantisco che non
appena abbiamo messo piede nei campi
profughi è stato chiaro che ciò che
facevamo aveva assolutamente senso un
grandissimo senso
queste persone sono persone che hanno
pochissimo e che ricevono aiuti
internazionali
solamente per ciò che riguarda i primi
le prime necessità medicina il cibo
l'acqua ossia roba fondamentale ma
l'essere umano non si nutre solo di cibo
ha bisogno anche di cibo per la mente
per per l'anima lo sappiamo tutti lo
sappiamo tutti
vedere ragazzi che appena usciti da
scuola hanno solo il deserto davanti a
loro perché vivono nel sarà ci fa capire
che questo vuoto va riempito e portare
una discussione su un tema come
l'astronomia che genera attività sul
momento durante la nostra visita e poi
può guidare l'immaginazione a compiere
nuove attività a viaggiare con la mente
a pensare fuori dagli schemi
forse sì a divergere dal loro destino
che sembra segnato è quello di essere
nel deserto in una zona arida e
invivibile
anche le popolazioni che vivono in
queste condizioni sono sotto lo stesso
cielo che il nostro motto essere tutti
sotto lo stesso cielo con noi come di
campobasso con noi italiani con noi
europei con noi con loro sudamericani o
con noi sudamericani e così via
siamo tutti sotto lo stesso cielo tutti
nella stessa astronave che viaggia nello
spazio interstellare
grazie
[Applauso]